ceci n'est pas un trucage cela leur est
en train de s'exercer en plein milieu de
la place saint marc levy nice hier ont
l'habitude de marcher dans l'eau mais
cette fois-là crû de près de deux mètres
dépasse toutes les prévisions
et on attend tu as été mon avis on a
mérité cette résidente manifestement
ébranlé raconte qu'une sorte du ragga a
déferlé sur la ville
c'était horrible dit elle en pleine nuit
des magasins ou des réceptions d'hôtel
ont été envahies par les flots des
gondoles et des bateaux autobus projeter
sur les trottoirs
la célèbre cité des doges a été submergé
la majestueuse basilique saint marc a
subi des dommages très importants au
rez-de-chaussée et dans la crypte
millions hilda il y aura des millions
d'euros de dégâts estime ce responsable
du monument le plus connu de la ville
ils étaient seuls en référer à des
chaudières encore ajoutant qu a dit m
nous avons déjà dit que la basilique
vieillissait de 20 ans à chaque
inondation
mais cela risque d'être beaucoup plus
encore cette fois venise est encore en
grande difficulté pour ses déplacements
dans les transports en commun nous avons
eu deux pics de montée des eaux dans la
journée ce matin c'était difficile pour
rejoindre son travail
la plupart des commerces étaient fermés
et les vénitiens la plupart des
résidents sont restés à la maison
l'avenir de venise est en jeu dit le
maire on ne peut plus vivre comme ça
notre crédibilité internationale en
dépend les demandent l'aide de l'état
italien pour limiter les dégâts et
n'hésite pas à attribuer cette
catastrophe au réchauffement climatique
mondial
les commerçants sont excédés les
commerçants sont même fatigués ils
passent des nuits entières dans leur
magasin pouvoir surveiller leurs
marchandises et limiter la perte de
cette marchandise
d'autre part nous avons la présence de
touristes qui sont plutôt enchanté
d'assister à un phénomène aussi
exceptionnel projet de protection de
venise par d'immenses digue rétractable
est en construction depuis plus de dix
ans à cause de problèmes multiples liés
à des scandales de corruption
le projet a coûté plus de 6 milliards
d'euros
sans résultats tangibles pour l'instant
un défi de plus pour ce joyau maritime
construit sur pilotis fréquenté par des
millions de touristes et qui s'enfonce
inexorablement dans la mer depuis une
bonne dizaine de siècles et sylvain
desjardins radio canada montréal